okay hey everyone its micromotor pose
and this is the overflows trader weekly
group training from Monday September 17
2018 again I apologize with technical
difficulties we had in the room and I'm
recording this after the session right I
did do a live session but without the
actual screen share but before I could
begin a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
training contains substantial risk and
is not for every investor and investor
could potentially lose although more
than the initial investment risk capital
is money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for training and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
training past reports it's not
necessarily indicative of future results
all right so there was a few things I
wanted to talk about but I mean the main
thing that I wanted to talk about in in
the room in the training was you know
taking trades in context of the market
as to what's happening in the market you
know you know no matter how you analyze
the market doing it by signal is gonna
get sell signals however you know don't
just take them blindly you know try to
put everything what's happening in the
market in context right if you're taking
a buy signal after a big rally you gotta
be asking yourself I mean how much more
is there to that rally just as you know
if the market has a big sell-off then
all you got a sell signal
you know how much left is I mean can the
market keep going lower of course it can
but you know at some point the markets
gonna start bothering me about and then
start reversing so you know what do I
mean by taking trades in context okay
for example if a lot of people that use
order flow look for stacked imbalances
right that's this green area up here at
the top you know it's three or more
imbalances stacked on top of each other
now you know is this a trade I'd be
looking to take no not at this point you
know we just had this nice big rally up
from the low here at you know 74 you
know 47 whatever that was and we rally
up all the way up to 70 120 okay so you
know you're talking about 75 cent move
and then you get a stack buying the
balance okay think about what's
happening in the market okay you just
had a 70 cent rally
the crude off the low and your 70 cents
higher okay what does that mean you know
you're gonna have people coming in late
to the party you know in the old days
iasts in the old days in the past used
to say well it's the the retail people
that finally you know got to the phone
and place their orders with their broker
to get long and you know that's the
cause of the stack and balance but you
know probably not in this case you know
it's it's not a very deep rich stacking
balance you know on the way up you have
you know near stacking balances you got
a lot of bars with three three
imbalances in them and then you get the
stacked imbalance now you know what I
mean you know take it in context or you
just has so many cents move you get a
buying signal I'm not looking to buy
after a move of 75 cents in fact I'd be
thinking the opposite I'd probably be
looking for a reason to sell now not
saying we just had a 75 cent move okay
now it's time to sell know if
something's happening in the order flow
then I'd be looking potentially to get
short I mean I do see some signs up here
with these prominent opponent controls
these bars with the fuchsia colors in
there but I definitely wouldn't be
looking to get long up here at that area
now you know the other thing that's
unique to my software is you know we
highlight the multiple imbalances in a
bar all right so a stacked imbalances
three or more imbalances stacked on top
of each other you see here seven again
zero 23 against one 18 against zero yeah
that's a stacking balance but there are
bars that have three imbalances in them
that are not stacked here you got zero
against 75 39 against 168 three against
39 now this is your loan down here the
low of the day I know because I got a
divergence signal here I can see this
green triangle there so I know that's
the low okay and what do I get as we're
starting to move off a level first I got
a divergence off the low and then as we
start moving higher I see multiple
imbalances coming in here okay to me
that's a good sign right I want to be
seen
aggressive buying coming in off the low
rather than after 75 cent move up then
Oh addresses by income in and I got to
get long we're try the beginning long
you know down here at 70 70 or up here
at 70 125 you know you're gonna want to
be getting
down here closer to the low rather than
up here near the high excuse me
so you know when I say take things in
context in market look at what's
happening in the market just as know if
a market is going sideways okay this is
growth forward here to some sideways
activity okay here all right scuse me
so this markets we're kind of stuck in a
range from about you know 6:00 in the
morning here we're looking a low around
70 70 or high up here around 70 95 so
about 25 cent move right in the middle
of that move around here at 70 80 to 83
you get a multiple stack stack selling
imbalance right you got 58 against 12 29
again 0 50 against 4 it's right in the
middle of that congestion do you think
it's gonna be very effective you know it
chances are it's not just as earlier
just as we're coming out of this you
know even you know I should let me step
it back a little bit here even in here
all right we're in this you know we hit
our high here at 71 88 then just went
sideways now here all right we get this
nice stack buying imbalance as you know
we're coming out through the high after
we had been sitting here since 3:30
until almost 6:30 excuse me I got you a
drink of water okay so we're in this
area right you hit a high at you know
3:30 and then we just went sideways
until 6 o'clock
6:30 so for the last three hours we've
been going sideways now we got a stack
buying imbalance okay now if you're a
breakout trader would you take that
trade yeah probably because he's
thinking okay we're making a new high
here we got you know stacked imbalance
we got aggressive buyers coming in
that's very very bullish now I gotta
admit I used to be a big guy on breakout
trading knowing that that was very early
on that was one of my main ways of
training was trading breakouts to new
highs or new lows
now did you make a new high in the next
bar yeah you did by was that about four
ticks so technically yeah they broke a
rib how it work but then it came right
back in and just start going sideways
didn't make an
hi up here to a 97 and then just revert
it back in and continue going sideways
so you know would I be interested in
taking this trade probably not because I
said it's it's we've been trading
sideways for three hours you know you're
starting to break out you know can we go
higher yeah of course we can we did yeah
we went higher by you know about eight
or nine ticks and then just started
going sideways again you know I'd rather
not be looking for reasons to be buying
up here at these highs especially if
you've just been trading there for the
last three hours and going nowhere now
you know then coming back to this stack
selling and balance now earlier I said
you know take it in context I'd rather
be looking for reasons to be selling up
in here however since 3:30 in the
morning back here until what time is
this here eight o'clock almost five
hours going nowhere okay I I'd be a
little bit hesitant to take this
maybe if we you know we're starting to
come out of this area right the sort of
this low of this consolidation move is
around seventy one hour sorry seventy
seventy we're still right smack dab in
the middle of it and then it fails now
again that's why I talked about when I
say y'all take trades in context you
could have the best trading signal but
if it comes in an area of congestion is
probably not going to be very effective
so you know that's what I mean by taking
trades in context think about where you
are for the day you know in the grand
scheme of things all right so let's just
walk it forward a little bit here so
that was that consolidation period so
let me come into the next area here
again now here's your high over here at
the way you have this divergence right
you got the negative Delta and the new
high and you know mark excels off a
little bit and then it comes back up as
you're just below that high you got a
stack mine and balanced again you know
just like earlier you had this coming
into this new high yet stacked buying in
balance now here you got another stack
buying a balance now share something
with you
I prefer stack buying imbalances to come
immediately after a new high is made not
as you're going into the high
and why is that is because you know here
you can see like the high is here at
the by in sac mine imbalances ends at 71
11 up here you know this is so many 121
and then you got this nice stack buying
imbalances because what I'm looking for
is to break out to the new high and
trigger stops or whatever is back there
if there are stops and then you know
build on itself and keep going now you
know this one comes just under that high
so I'm not really interested in that one
you know this one yeah it is breaking
out through the high but I would just
like to take this whole piece here put
it just above the high for it to appear
not have it appear you know sort of as
you're going into the high you know when
I was training for you know JP Morgan
you know I'm not trying to drop names or
anything but I used to do this stuff you
know I used to try and trigger stops I
mean anybody can trigger a stop right
all it takes is one contract for us you
know whatever stops in the order book to
get triggered I mean nowadays maybe they
got some you know maybe some of these
algos are a bit more fancy like it's got
a trade a certain amount of quantity
before I'll trigger stop I remember we
were working on setting up that sort of
algo at JP Morgan where you know say you
know you say you know like here's the
high 71 22 21 and I put a stop in here
at 25 but I would say you know only if a
trades
you know 25 contracts if it trades one I
don't want to just get in a high tick or
an uptick and trigger my stop off so you
know I'm sure nowadays it's a bit more
advanced they've they've probably come
up with that technology for it's not
that complex but I remember we were
working on it back in 2012 2010 mainly
for spreads used to work a lot of
spreads and wood last thing we want to
see is one or two contracts traded then
we get stopped out on 500 spreads now
this stack selling a balance I'd be
interested in honestly it's you know we
come up here made new high start selling
off decks on imbalance see oh we got
three bars negative Delta I do like that
no I don't like this bar right here with
the small Delta what I'd like to see
immediately after the
is a bar with nice healthy negative
Delta not a small Delta and then here
starts coming back you got the stack
mind and balance you know positive Delta
55 you actually got a delta surge going
on in here
you got 55 326 406 stack mine and
balance and it's back up to the races we
make out to the new high and you know it
looks like to me this is what stop looks
like getting triggered right in here and
you know I did probably about 100 150 so
it's 250 300 what is that okay ed now
550 you know it's probably a thousand
contracts traded in here right in here
and it didn't notice this makes us
vacuum it doesn't even come back to fill
it and that's how you know how strong it
is when you start seeing stacked buying
imbalances that don't fill it in it's
usually a pretty strong move so then we
come up here now again you know take it
in context right where would you rather
be if you're gonna take stack behind and
balance up here when you have it up here
or down here just as you broke out to
the new high you know where you got a
reason you got something some stops
being triggered in here you haven't
pulled back to fill that in because if
it was just you know if it was a okay a
weak move but you know it stops being
triggered and probably you know
something else and the fundamentals came
in 71 in a quarter
looks like this level is obviously it's
a quarter so it's probably got some you
know psychological thing going on in
there then okay so you know we start
making this new high and make a new high
make a new high then when you get up
here okay so up here at the new high you
got a nice prominent point of control
this fuchsia color here well then you
start selling off you got this
stacks on and balance in here right off
the high no that's what I like to see
and the market you know starts trading
lower comes up sort of test that area
where they had the stack sentence
telling the ballasts you know notice how
it comes right back up to the cusp of
that level in the bottom of the level
and then continues on down so you know
try and take it in context again I like
stacked imbalances if buying a balance
if we're breaking out after the new
highs have been made or the new lows
have been made forced excellent balance
I don't like it as we're coming in there
because you know I think it's someone
trying to push that market
trying to see trying to probe if there's
anything up in there you know there
wasn't and you know I said if we're up
here near a high and I see a stack sound
and balance coming in I would like it I
like this one it just didn't get that
that follow up selling right what you
need is the follow-up selling to come
inside there and help move the market
lower in this case it didn't do that up
here you know we're hanging up here at
the high you got the negative Delta's
now the other thing about this high it's
quite interesting is as we're coming up
into that high notice the deltas you
know you got negative 293 here you got -
237 minus 162 - 443 got a small Delta of
8 minus 1 17 and you got three bars in
here two of which are you know kind of
nice strong or 183 143 but then this one
66 eight then - 400 - 700 yeah that's
the kiss of death right there as you see
this Delta getting extremely strong
negative up in here where do you see a
negative
what do you see a Delta number a period
where the positive or negative anywhere
in here not till way back here so all of
a sudden now we're seeing the aggressive
sellers coming in right as the market is
about the tank excuse me so you know if
you're getting short somewhere up in
here off the stack sound and balance you
know anywhere in here
you know called anywhere between 71 40
and 70 155 you know we trade all the way
down down down below 70 100 you know and
look at this Delta don't we need to
watch prices watch this Delta anytime
you get positive Delta's it's kind of
small you know going back here 66 25
5453 22 42 negative Delta's - two
hundred you know - three hundred - 200 -
200 you get one bar here positive Delta
421 okay fine fair enough doesn't mean
this whole move is over if we start
seeing a few bars coming here with
strong positive Delta then I would have
second thoughts but then it just
continues - 112 - 121 is $1.99 - 472 -
524 until the market you know calm
all the way down here down down down
down to this area you got a prominent
point of control down here even down
here you know to me this is this is the
end but again you know this stack mine
imbalance yeah I might be interested I'd
be interested I would say I might you
know this is one I'd be interested in
it's coming right after this nice swing
low starting to string together some
positive Delta in here but didn't you
what I would do is got to watch the
Delta in the next bar if it comes back
with a decent strong negative Delta I'm
not gonna be interested I think it will
fail and in this case it obviously it
does fail and the market just keeps
going lower alright so you know there's
a question that came up in the room
dealing with single prints right now on
the software if there's a single print
in the bar on a green candle it'll color
it in green on a red candle it will
color it in red if it appears at the top
of a red candle or the bottom of a love
a green candle and again it's it's not
some fancy indicator all it is it's a
visual thing because for me it's it's
important in the order flow in my
analysis and it always has been and now
the question that came up was what do
you do when you start seeing alternating
the opposite was the term that was used
single prints like here we got green and
you got red then you got green well to
me it's more of a sign of a market going
sideways rather than you know anything
special now where I like to see single
prints is at you know if it's a up move
I'd like to see it at the end of an up
move like up here you got one
we got a single print I like to see it
there just as you know if it was on a
move down I would like to see it you
know at a swing low or a swing high now
if we're in a move I like to see you
know I can just move up you see single
print single print single print I like
to see it on a move up it just helps
confirm to me that there's very little
selling occurring at the bottoms of
these bars obviously that because you
can see the volume right for you know
three one you know and even down here
for as well I suppose like 5611 you know
twenty two or twenty
3:44 it just tells me that you know
there's just not a lot of selling
interest peering down there and that's
what I like to see you know on a move up
here you know one eight three seven one
you know it just helps confirm the move
to me now again it's not some special
fancy indicator it's just something that
highlights it to you if you're not using
my software you just got to look at it
but I'm a visual person I like to you
know I'm looking at a lot of stuff
during the day you know I've got my
charts open sometimes I'm busy reading
the news you know there's fascinating
stuff going on in the world these days
and you know you can't keep up with it
half the time and so I need something
that's a bit visual to me rather than
sitting here after stare at the screen
you know being able to see something
highlighted - that to me is is worth
worth the money you know like here I up
here you know you can keep confusing
you're up here at your high I notice the
high guide divergence up here I got this
single print to me that's just that's
where I like to see the single prints
I'm not interested in this one here
necessarily this there's two Lots but
I'm more interested in up here at the
high and it sort of goes back to us
talking about earlier with taking things
in context right I thought I see it if
I'm looking for a single print that a
high I'm looking for a single print near
the high you know on the upside in the
sense of you know on a red bar on a bar
that's turning down rather than on a
green bar up here I mean yeah we
couldn't keep going higher but I mean we
were hitting these heís got divergence
divergence you know every time we hit a
high we come off we hit a high we come
off hit a high we come off but if I
start seeing a sign up here that maybe
this move is over I'm going to be
interested in because I'm already seeing
the signs up in here in these bars up in
here
you know I got the divergence I got this
prominent point of control up in here I
got the single print and we start making
this move you know the small move down
so that's that's how I like to look at
single prints now again if I start
seeing them alternating then to me
that's more of a sign of a market going
sideways you know there's different ways
in the order flow I can determine if a
market is going sideways and why is that
important is because if I can determine
markets going sideways I'm gonna wait
till we get out of this
activity you know before I can catch a
move you know you're not gonna train
sideways you're not gonna go anywhere
and you end up gonna get chopped up so
you know how I like to see it is you
know if we're breaking out like here you
got this hi
start breaking out then we start moving
higher single print single print single
print you know that tells me that this
move is moving higher now if I were to
start seeing the other market pulling
back like if this bar up here had a
single print okay maybe this move is
over but I'm not seeing any single
prints up here just as we we had this
rally up here at this high who got a
single print and then we just sort of
going sideways another single print
another single print so we're starting
to group some single prints up in here
as the markets start coming off a little
bit so again no take everything in
context of the market with what's
happening that's gonna put you in good
steed so that was it the other stuff was
just I remember a bit maintenance
housekeeping stuff so thanks and again
it's trying to get this up online for
everybody so you guys could watch it and
enjoy thank you again bye bye